des hectares d'aspères a récolté pleine
saison le manque de main d'oeuvre s'est
fait ressentir avec l'épidémie du
coronavirus malgré la réouverture des
frontières pour les travailleurs
saisonniers
la production annuelle de plus de 130
mille tonnes n'aurait pas pu être
récoltés en allemagne si les
agriculteurs n'avaient pas pu compter
sur l'aide des étudiants pour les
récolter
pour les entrepreneurs pour le secteur
de production d'aspergés très difficile
en ce moment nous sommes très heureux
qu'il y ait des étudiants qu'ils
puissent apporter leur aide
mais je pense de manière générale que la
situation est difficile parce qu'il ya
sans nul doute un double fardeau d'un
côté il n'ya pas d'ouvriers ou de main
d'oeuvre bon marché que les cultivateurs
des asperges peuvent embaucher et d'un
autre côté les ventes sont en chute sur
les marchés de gros c'est le secteur de
la restauration le secteur privé en
général qui hésitent à acheter et
globalement cela rend la situation
difficile pour les entreprises de notre
secteur
tout le monde s'est immédiatement porté
volontaire ils sont venus en voiture ont
pris rendez vous avec moi
si nous pouvons vous aider nous devons
vous aider sans exagérer ils sont venus
sur place de même le soir et m'ont dit
nous voulons vous aider
une nouvelle activité qui aide
financièrement les étudiants
alors pour moi par exemple cela signifie
que je suis davantage en mesure de payer
mon loyer parce qu'il ya un forfait de
450 euros
certains le font un temps plein d'autres
non cela dépend évidemment de votre
productivité
je me suis juste dit et bien que j'avais
prévu de prendre quelques job à temps
partiel mais ils ont tous été annulés et
gagner un peu d'argent mais je voulais
quand même aider un peu à l'heure où
l'europe est confiné pour se protéger de
la pandémie
l'allemagne affrète des vols spéciaux
pour accueillir de la main d'oeuvre
venant d'europe de l'est
des employés qui vont probablement
prendre le relais des étudiants bavarois